dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaifer
let's talk about snow simulations being
able to simulate snow
on our computers is not new it's been
possible for a few years now
for instance this legendary disney paper
from 2013
was capable of performing that so
why do researchers write new papers on
this topic
well because the 2013 paper had its
limitations
let's talk about them while looking at
some really sweet footage from a new
paper
limitation number one for previous works
is that their snow simulations
were sinfully expensive most of them
took not
seconds and sometimes not even minutes
but half an hour per frame yes
that means all nighter simulations they
were also
not as good in fracturing interactions
simulating powder snow
and avalanches were also out of reach
until now you see simulating snow
is quite challenging it clamps up
deforms
breaks and hardens under compression
and even my favorite phase change from
fluid to snow
these are all really challenging to
simulate properly
and in a moment you will see that this
new method is capable
of even more beyond that let's start
with friction
first we turn on the snow machine
and then engage the wipers that looks
wonderful and now may i request seeing
some tire marks
there you go this looks really good so
how about taking a closer look at this
phenomenon
vb here is the boundary friction
coefficient
and it is a parameter that can be chosen
freely
by us so let's see what that looks like
if we initialize this to a low value
we'll get very little friction
and if we crank this up look things get
a great deal more sticky
a big clump of snow also breaks apart in
a spectacular manner
also showcasing compression and
fracturing
beyond the boundary friction effect we
just looked at
oh my this is beautiful
okay now this is a computer graphics
paper
if you're a seasoned fellow scholar you
know what this means
it means that it is time to put some
virtual bunnies into the oven
this is a great example for rule number
one for watching physics simulations
which is that we discussed the physics
part and
not the visuals so why are these bunnies
blue
well let's chuck them into the oven and
find out
aha they are color coded for temperature
look they start from -100 celsius
that's the blue and we see the colors
change as they approach
0 degrees celsius at this point they
don't yet start melting
but they are already falling apart so it
was
indeed a good design decision to show
the temperatures
because it tells us exactly what is
going on here
without this we would be expecting
melting
well can we see that melting in action 2
you bet now hold on to your papers
and bring forth the soft isomat
this machine can not only create an
exquisite dessert
for computer graphics researchers but
also showcases the individual
contributions of this new technique
one by one there is the melting
yes add the little frosting
and there you go
bon appetit now as we feared
many of these larger scale simulations
require computing the physics
for millions of particles so how long
does that take
when we need millions of particles we
typically have to wait
a few minutes per frame but if we have a
smaller scene we can get away with these
computations in a few
seconds per frame goodness we went from
hours per frame
to seconds per frame in just one paper
outstanding work and also wait a second
if we are talking millions of particles
i wonder
how much memory it takes to keep track
of them
let's see whoa this
is very appealing i was expecting a few
gigabytes
yet it only asks for a fraction of it a
couple hundred megabytes
so with this hefty value proposition it
is no wonder that this paper has been
accepted to the siggraph conference
this is the olympic gold medal of
computer graphics research if you will
huge congratulations to the authors of
this paper this was
quite an experience what a time to be
alive
this episode has been supported by lamda
gpu cloud
if you're looking for inexpensive cloud
gpus for ai
check out lambda gpu cloud they've
recently launched quadro
rtx 6000 rtx 8000 and v100 instances
and hold on to your papers because
lambda gpu cloud
can cost less than half of aws
and azure plus they are the only cloud
service with 48 gigabyte
rdx 8000 join researchers at
organizations like apple mit and caltech
in using lambda cloud instances
workstations or servers
make sure to go to lambdalabs.com papers
to sign up
for one of their amazing gpu instances
today our thanks to lambda for their
long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time